looking good has never been so easy or
cheap from shoes to hats to dresses you
can buy all the latest fashion trends
while ballin on a budget this whole
outfit would cost from your own sixty
bucks that puts the real cost of these
clothes Americans are buying more
clothes than ever this thanks in large
part to the fast fashion industry fast
fashion is like fast food it's the cheap
version of the good stuff sold in huge
quantities and the turnaround is Swift
knockoff Runway styles make it to
mainstream stores like H&M forever 21
and Zara sometimes as often as once a
week and that outfit probably won't last
much longer than a few washes ever since
fast fashion stores came on the scene in
the 90s clothing prices have actually
gone down even when prices for
everything else have gone up you can
think cheap materials and labor for that
so even though we're buying more
Americans are using only about 3% of
their spending budgets on clothing
compared to 10% in 1960 so what is this
cute $8 shirt only lastly one party I'll
just get it on the dolls and throw this
away but our addiction to cheap clothing
has gotten so out of hand that our
clothing waste is piling up every year
85% of our clothes and other textiles go
into landfills that's 70 pounds of waste
per person the remaining 15 percent gets
donated or recycled even secondhand
stores don't know what to do with our
leftovers there's a Salvation Army
distribution center in New York City
that processes 5 tons of used clothes
every single day there's no way they can
sell it all so they end up shipping half
of their stuff overseas our reliance on
all these new cheap clothes affects our
skies and water to textile dyes make up
1/5 of industrial water pollution and
it's estimated that the apparel industry
makes up 10% of the global carbon
footprint and let's not forget how fast
fashion affects workers around the world
factory workers in places like China
Bangladesh and the Philippines often
don't make a living wage and are subject
to poor and dangerous working conditions
companies like H&M have said they're
committed to changing their
environmental and labor practices they
want to be more sustainable but what's
actually sustainable about fast fashion
not much in fact until we as consumers
change our habits we'll be stuck in a
revolving door of five dollar tank tops
and seven dollar hippy headbands that
produce more waste that someone was paid
pennies to make so what's a fashionista
to do ask yourself if it's worth buying
something that you may not wear more
than a couple of times
recycled there are textile recycling
programs that turn your radius shirt
into pillow stuffing and buy less buy
used by better because remember that hot
tub might be hella cute and trendy but
what price are you willing to pay for
fast fashion